well brian the fremont street experience
has a big party planned tonight to
celebrate
the full reopening that's where we find
eight news now reporter madison
kimbrough with a look at
what's on deck starting at 1201 a.m
madison how
how's it going up out there
yeah christian things are just getting
started here as you can see i'm going to
step out of the way so you can really
take a look it's still early
but of course there are a lot of people
out this memorial day you can see
and starting at 10 30 tonight fremont
street will experience
their hosting they're calling it the
downtown rocks
again three music stages will be set up
where people of all ages
can come on down and enjoy live tunes
from a variety of bands
that will be playing and the viva vision
canopy screens will be running a
countdown clock counting down to
midnight but that's not all
a red carpet will also be rolled out at
10 30.
as for parking it will be tough tonight
so it's important that you prepare and
give yourself enough time
because it is expected to be a larger
than life turnout tonight
now the parking garage off of 4th street
will be open and that's probably going
to be your best bet
as for attendees a recorded message by
our mayor
mayor goodman will be shown and fremont
experience officials will all be
in attendance this event tonight is
expected to last until
4am with live music playing until then
so get ready you guys i'm going to send
it back to you in the studio as you can
see
it is busy